Princess Leia's journey from an orphaned
prisoner of the Empire into a kick-ass
space general there's been nothing short
of stellar to watch over the decades but
the history behind the Star Wars
character is a fascinating galaxy unto
itself
he is the untold truth of Princess Leia
a symbol of hope
Star Wars creator George Lucas developed
many of the franchise characters named
based on their phonetic pleasantry how
good they feel to say and to hear and a
determination to steer clear from some
of the more common sci-fi naming
conventions but for leia organa he took
things a step further her name is a play
on princess Dejah Thoris from Edgar Rice
Burroughs John Carter of Mars stories
combined of lady Galadriel from JRR
Tolkien's Lord of the Rings Dejah
Galadriel Leia sounds about right
meanwhile Organa comes from a more
obvious source as it's meant to sound
like the word organic as a nod to the
fact that Leia and her rebels represent
a more natural life loving side of
things than the Deaf style wielding
Empire the hairstyle few have been able
to lay claim to a fashion moment as
their own as much as Leia and a cinnamon
bun style hairdo interestingly enough
however that hemispherical hair almost
didn't make it into the movie in the
first place the original concept artwork
for Leia had no such hairstyle drawn in
but Lucas landed on the look as a
tribute to 20th century Mexican
revolutionary women he told Time
magazine that he wanted to capture a
kind of southwestern Pancho Villa woman
revolutionary look the buns are
basically from turn-of-the-century
Mexico unfortunately historians have
since stepped forward to dispute his
characterization of that era but there
was reportedly an Arizonian tribe of
women called the hopi who wore their
hair in a similar fashion around the
1920s perhaps not coincidentally the
cultural adoption of the hopi squash
blossom style by non tribal women of the
era was seen as an act of rebellion and
feminism for splitting from the
mainstream style I know who you are
you came from now on you do as I tell
you
decades later fish's own daughter Billie
lourd wore ear muffs on scream queens as
a subtle tribute to her mom's iconic
look the twins
some Star Wars fans still have trouble
watching the scene in Empire Strikes
Back when Leia plants a smooch on a
secret brother Luke Skywalker even
though the two didn't know they were
related until Return of the Jedi
it still doesn't sit very well knowing
what we know from later in the series
and Mark Hamill himself has said it had
a lasting impact on the character this
has naturally drummed up some questions
about whether the two were originally
intended to be brother and sister in the
first place rumor has it that in the
original draft for Empire Strikes Back
Luke's sister was actually named nella
ladies first
when Star Wars first debuted in 1977
Princess Leia was among the first film
toys that kids got to place on their
shelves the company that made the
original action figures for the series
released a set of four figures Luke r2d2
Chewbacca and Princess Leia who wielded
her own blaster - that meant that layer
figures predated both Han Solo and Darth
Vader in collectability and that she was
recognized as more than just some damsel
in distress from the get-go costuming
gripes Carrie Fisher was undoubtedly the
lifeblood that made Leia so special on
screen so it should come as little
surprise that like a counterpart Fisher
became known as being a bit rebellious
her wit her resistance to being labeled
as a sex part was awesome a mainstay of
her post Star Wars fame and she was
particularly outspoken about the
challenges of some of Laius costumes for
example Fisher revealed in a comedic
stand-up special turned memoir wishful
drinking
that's George Lucas instructed her not
to wear a bra under her infamous white's
dress because to his mind women in space
wouldn't wear underwear for fear they'll
be strangled in zero-gravity situations
the infamous gold bikini Leia wore while
imprisoned by Jabba the Hutt's during
Return of the Jedi was also a subject of
some discord with Fisher who kindly
advised the force awakens actress Daisy
Ridley to resist a similar fate
however Fisher ultimately made peace
with the costume by create
her own backstory for the look in
response to a citizen movement to have
Slave Leia items removed from Star Wars
merchandise he said to the father who
flipped out about it what am I going to
tell my kid about why she's in that
outfit tell them a giant slug captured
me and forced me to wear that stupid
outfit and then I killed him because I
didn't like it and then I took it off
backstage Leia in real life in fish's
final memoir The Princess Diaries she
revealed the intense love affair she and
Han Solo actor Harrison Ford engaged in
during filming and how it bled into the
movie itself
she explained in 2016 that the pair had
a wild night out with the cast of Monty
Python and the Rolling Stones included a
spirits concoction called the Tunisian
death drink and kept them up all night
until their cool time the next day for
the Cloud City scene their smiles were
there for a reason
bonus spirits shortly after fish is
unexpected passing in late 2016 a
deleted scene from The Force awakens
went viral due to its epic display of
the characters grit and wit in the
matter of just a few sentences or maybe
thank you I don't care for many the
moment was a perfect example of Laius
growth and tenacity throughout the
series book ending her unending
willingness to fight for the Republic
she's one with the force
there's another question that's long
urged audiences of the Star Wars series
why didn't Leia who was not only force
sensitive but strong ever become a Jedi
herself according to the force awakens
director JJ Abrams though it was a mere
matter of the character's own choice he
explained that it was a topic of
conversation between himself Lucas and
Fisher drawing the development of
episode 7 and that they all decided that
while there was no age limit at which a
person could be trained as a Jedi Knight
it was simply a choice layer made that a
decision to run the rebellion and
ultimately this resistance and consider
herself a general as opposed to a Jedi
was simply a choice that she took she's
still four strong and it's something
that I think is an intrinsic piece of a
character making it her call all along
certainly seems fitting for the princess
nay general may the force be with you
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]